Wilson County Sheriff Joe Tackett is
with us now sheriff thank you for being
here let me start with how the folks who
are still in the hospital are doing this
morning we understand at this point that
there are stable condition you know
that's about all we know at this time
where is your investigation right now
well right now it's kind of at a
standstill people are trying to get some
rest and we still got a lot of shell
casings and things we need to go through
over there at the church and it's going
to take hours to do that but you know
the suspect is deceased so at this point
we don't have you know anyone to start
questioning tell me more about how he
how you believe he came into the
building and then also what happened
after well we believe he was over here
at this station convenience store and
then went across went around the church
firing rounds and then came back to the
front and went in the front door went
all the way up to the front
firing as he was going and then turned
around going out the door at that point
we believe he dropped his his rifle a
citizen was across the street they
engaged in firefight for just a little
bit the suspect gets in his vehicle it
takes off this I'm calling my hero here
in town
then stops a truck lagana truck and says
I need help this guy just shot up the
church
follow it so the two guys involved now
in following him or right in this this
truck and you know there was some
gunfire exchanged I think on the roadway
also and then he wrecked out and at this
time we believe that he had a
self-inflicted dunk shot he shot himself
after he pulled over after wreck down
you grew up here yes tell me about this
community this is a close-knit community
I mean everybody here in the community
knows everyone you know and and to help
each other and it's just gonna be
traumatic for a lot of people but
they're gonna come together they're
strong people you know you're very very
busy Sheriff
so thank you for your time our thoughts
are with you this morning okay
appreciate it take care